yo yo what's up GQ it's Moses the
Jeweler and I'm back to break down some
crazy celebrity
[Music]
watches we have Bad Bunny wearing a
white gold automar Paget 39 mm this is
with the chronograph and old factory
jump set diamonds I know Drake has one
of these in his collection too so I'm
sporting this one time very rare very
different as you see in the sub dials
also you have three different colors of
pearl the way the light hits it if you
see the watch in person which I have
seen it it's gorgeous retail I would
have to assume probably around like 140
150,000 I do notice a discontinued piece
the secondary Market you're paying well
over 200 to flood out this whole thing
and make it look like this they used to
do it a lot for the ladies now it became
really popular with the men men want to
bling you know what I'm saying same
thing with the hip-hop jewelry back in
the '90s most people wearing the plain
gold now everyone diamonds diamonds
diamonds they want to be flooded
out over here we have Travis Scott
wearing something crazy this is a 5719
this is done in white gold as I said
before padic Philip they're setting
diamonds they're using the best quality
the highest quality if for a rapper of
this caliber he wants a factory so here
he's rocking that on stage it's a
superstar piece this one will run you
around
$750,000 it's a crazy bezel and I love
the contrast between the round cut
diamonds and the baguette Cuts in the
center it's like again such different
shine different pop from every area it's
like they did an incredible job with
this one it's a light show it's a light
show I've seen this one in person I was
going to pull out my credit card keep it
for myself but it's going to run me too
much but the way that this thing shines
you're going to need sunglasses it's
crazy right here we got a maluma rocking
a automar pag Royal o skeleton one of my
dream pieces this is a reference 15412
BC so over here you have like three of
the best things in the world we got here
the open work which of course AP is
famously known for we got the rainbow
bezel which AP Cho is the finest quality
gems for their rainbow bezel and then we
got the Florentine finish as they like
to say the Frosted finish on the band
and the amount of work and time that
goes into creating a piece like this
incredible and AP does it best and this
is why a piece like this is going to
cost you over half a million dollars for
your
collection since retirement Tom Brady's
been going crazy this padic pH it goes
for a retail price of $108,000 and on
the secondary Market they're looking at
closer to $250,000 range right now this
is an incredible piece an incredibly
rare piece and a piece that has a big
demand at the top of its Market seeing
them even close to 400,000 this is a
Daytona reference 6241 in solid yellow
gold and something very rare over here
is you actually see this Daytona in a
jubilee band which you don't see I wish
Rolex were to bring it back this is an
extremely iconic piece classic piece
that this definitely call it him a
pretty penny if I'd have to assume I'd
say something like this is like half a
million dollars on the market Daytona
became popular once Paul Newman sported
it back in like the late 60s early 70s
this Daytona is the iconic look this is
the one that made all these daytonas hot
and going for a crazy special premium
it's recognizable right away because of
its dial you have three sub dials in the
center and whenever you see the Rolex
silhouette with that dial automatic
Daytona right here we got Tom Brady
wearing probably the most controversial
piece of the Year this is the Rolex Day
Day 36 mm with the puzzle dial so it's
funny with the day and date you have a
function I'll take off my watch to show
the people with the day date you have
the function in order to read the day
and the date on its dial and on this
piece Rolex first of all they switched
out the day and the date for emojis as
the date function and for the day they
had different sayings like love and so
on a lot of people said that Rolex went
off of their classic look when they
created this and some people were
against it me personally I love it it
kind of shows no limits in this world it
kind of shows that the you you got to
push the boundary you know it was for a
good cause it was for children with
autism so they wenter really colorful
with this I'm a big fan of this one
super limited it was an off catalog
piece I do believe the retail was around
58,000 for this they were fetching a
high retail for it resil is going to be
crazy so over here you got the date
window and the day window which makes it
a date date of
course over here we got Ed Shar and
we're on a crazy AP Royal Oak concept
Spider-Man this is an AP concept uh
silhouette which has a different
silhouette than your average AP which
has that octagonal shape this one has a
little more curvature and this one is
actually done in Titanium with a black
ceramic bezel and a black ceramic Crown
Marvel actually collaborated with ap in
order to create two different versions
they created a black Panther and over
here you have the Spider-Man which is uh
we call this big boy toys it's not your
Spider-Man that came in a Happy Meal as
we say this is one that uh costs at
around uh
$215,000 price range that all the money
did go for a charity something like this
especially when it's numbered in crazy
high demand minimal two times over the
retail value which is 215 so something
like this could set you back at least
half a million and then a really up
Market some people even pay up to a
million dollars for a piece like this so
over here we have John Mayor and Ed
Sheran wearing the same same watches on
stage together which makes them around
the 1% of the collectors in the world
when you have 250 pieces two of them are
right next to each other which is pretty
awesome to see and of course big shout
out to John Mayer crazy collector cheer
and had to show him that he can go
head-to-head with
him we have John Mayor wearing a Royal
Oak in yellow gold this one's actually a
37 mm so reference 15550 ba I'm a little
jealous looking at this one this is a
piece that I actually wanted to add to
my own collection I'm still looking for
it the special thing about this watch is
the dial it's Insanity so turquoise dial
is actually cut from a specific
turquoise stone so no dial is going to
be the same you have different veins and
different marble in every single one
which makes every single piece extremely
unique this is why AP makes such a
limited amount cuz they're very hard to
make something like this right now in
the secondary Market people probably pay
upward of like 170
80,000 when you're buying a watch like
this you're also buying into the company
of AP itself and you're buying their
best stock basically so when you have a
watch like this and you believe in AP
then uh something like this will only go
up in value I see it doubling to even
tripling in value in the next 5 to 10
years here we have Steve Harvey rock in
a rose gold RM 6501 I love that rose
gold and an RM is Sleek it's clean every
time you look deep into it you find
something else and something else and
something else and it's like this is
what makes Richard Mill Richard
Mill we got messy Rock in here Paddock
phip krava when you hear krava you think
very classic old man but uh we see him
rocking it on a nice sporty uh band
which kind of gives it that modern look
you have the baby blue hand with the
baby blue sshing classic clean piece and
something that is not going to break
your bank if you want to go into Paddock
the retail on this piece was around
35,000 and on the secondary Market
you're going to probably pay around 45
to 48,000 so you're not paying a crazy
premium to own a nice Paddock FIP that
you even see stars like lonel Messi
rocking light piece as he said let me
throw my white t-shirt and my $50,000
Paddock right over here we got Jacob
Alli wearing a very clean black suit
looks like he's at a red carpet event he
went with a cardier tank normal and 18
karat yellow gold went with a very
classic piece smaller face but um
sometimes big doesn't mean special
sometimes small means special also so
I'm like this it shouldn't break the
bank between 8 and 15,000 range
depending on condition and year and
stuff like that it's something not so
hard to get but also you're not going to
see every watch collector have this in
their collection if you don't want to be
so showy you're going to rock something
like this something that has a statement
of course cuz the gold but not big not
loud and then the black leather of
course kind of makes it more
subdued
AP Royal Oak 41 mm this one he's rocking
with the chronograph so you have two
different options you have the Chrono
and the non- Chrono Chrono is going to
cost you a little bit extra dollars
because of the functionality again
classic piece clean Sleek Rich dress it
up dress it down talks for itself this
is basically same mod that we do see
culu rocking but this one is in a 39 mm
K size same silhouette but of course a
different look in the center of the dial
this was a little more busy as we
say over here we got Chris Paul rocking
a yellow gold Vashon 222 I love those
numbers it's good luck he's sporting
your next to nice van CLE which I also
like me as a jeweler that's where my eye
goes to again very classic look Vashon
is also one of the best of what they do
different style different look Chris
Paul said everyone's rocking the Roes
and the aps let me throw on a nice
yellow gold vason stand out a little be
a little different it's a different band
you know every watch is famous for the
band that they do just like when we have
AP and you see this band you
automatically know AP when you see sound
like this and you see this band you
automatically think presidential day day
so over here vason did their own style
their own take on it if it catches as
good as this the price will definitely
go up got Brad Pit rocking the same bat
around over here I think he saw Chris
Paul rocking it he said you know what I
want one also that's the influence that
the celebrities have you know you see
one rocket they could change the market
for any for any watch at any
time over here we got ice spice rocking
a rm5 some diamonds on it I like the
combo she has over here we got the white
strap with the solid rolls gold then you
got those white diamonds hidden it looks
to me like it is a custom job on the RM
looks like the diamonds were added after
this isn't Factory Diamond set but uh
still a gorgeous job the diamonds are
shining this is almost like the uh the
starter RM they call it this one is not
the one that's going to break the bank
and cost you many hundred thousands this
one you're probably going to be paying
around 100,000 to 150,000 this is the
rm05 it's like the starter piece to get
in which will run you close to six
figures if you're looking to buy a watch
that's covered in diamonds I would buy a
factory if you're looking to hold its
value this is something that the company
stands behind you can always go and get
your watch service by Rolex AP if they
did set the diamonds this is something
that's very rare very hard to come
across and everyone knows the rules of
supply and demand the demand gets bigger
the supply becomes smaller price goes up
thank you guys thank you GQ for having
me I'll see you guys next
time